Joe Theismann former Notre Dame
quarterback obviously [ __ ]
quarterback is well a great football
analyst and he joins us now
good morning Joe how are you I'm a good
damn good to catch up with you current
state of Notre Dame football is what
extremely positive coming off of last
year's horrible performance a lot of
close games lost a lot of injured
players started with suspensions early
on and Brian Kelly I think has done a
terrific job redirecting this football
organization he has sort of stepped to
the side as far as play-calling goes and
really has become sort of the CEO of the
football operation and and he's got to
be a chip long run the offense who came
out of Memphis Mike elko came from West
Wake Forest to run the defense the
strength and conditioning program has
changed tremendously and I think that's
one of the big keys for Notre Dame as
its played this season as they seem to
get stronger as games go on as opposed
to losing some steam which they did a
year ago so lots of very positive things
going on in that program we don't Notre
Dame's been tested certainly got tested
at home with Georgia has Miami been
tested enough that you have an idea of
how good they're going to be this
weekend yeah you know I had an
opportunity over the last two weeks I
was at the Notre Dame USC game a few
weeks ago watched us play you know
everybody thought that would be a real
contest it turned out being a very
dominant win by Notre Dame and then I
had an opportunity to watch Virginia
Tech a Miami play in person down in
Miami this past weekend Miami is a it's
a tremendous group of athletes and marks
done a wonderful job putting these
athletes together they've won a lot of
games a lot of close games I mean
there's games that you think they're
going to lose they wind up somehow
finding a way to win which to me is just
resiliency
I think Notre Dame overall is a bit
bigger probably matches them speed for
speed and I think that was a big
advantage when it came to Miami because
they've always got great athletes
they're always really fast I think Notre
Dame has as much speed on the field on
both sides of the ball as Miami does but
I don't think they've been tested like
Notre Dame's gonna test them Joe
Theismann joining us on the program you
look at these quarterbacks you got a
chance to see Sam darn 'old
we get hyped up over these kids because
somebody's new that comes onto the scene
and then all of a sudden you know
defenses get a chance to go out him a
second time we get a chance to animal
analyze him a little bit more what did
you see from Sam Darnell Dan if you were
his father what advice would you give
him whether it's coming out or going
back I I would either always you know
first of all if you look at this class
it isn't just Sam coming out you know
Rosen coming out of UCLA kid out of
Wyoming there's probably about four or
five young men that are probably gonna
come into the game there's two ways to
look at it number one looking at the
young man I would always say go back for
another year of school go back and grow
up sociologically physiologically get
physically stronger continue to work on
your skills that's one part of it the
other side is we don't have quarterbacks
in the National Football League Dan
we're we've got older ones we got about
half a dozen that are in their late 30s
and we've got a bunch of teams that
really need it we have about 10 to 11 12
football teams that really need
quarterbacks going forward
I mean Arizona's gonna be looking Denver
is gonna be looking Jacksonville always
look at Cleveland's always looking the
Jets are always looking so if you're
coming out if you wanted to come out
this year there's going to be a place
for you in the first round so you know
as as advice as a parent I to get your
education because you can't believe me
and I know injury could end your career
quickly the other side of it is with the
salary cap in place for rookies the
amount of money you make in this
contract is not monumental like it used
to be mm-hmm
you know we're not looking at the Sam
Bradford numbers anymore we're looking
at a max I think a 21 over a five-year
period you know like for example take
dak Prescott contract there's a 400,000
I think last year yeah not counting the
bonus and and so you know the economics
aren't there to drive it so as a parent
I take get your education go back for
another year of school but then as a
player
what's that school got on the field to
support you because you've heard me say
this many times the quarterback position
is the single most dependent position on
the field now if you're going back to a
school that graduates doesn't seniors
and it's going to be a difficult road
for you then you look at go
into professional football like you
would go into a job I'm gonna go
someplace where I get a chance to be
able to work on my trade so it's it's
you know it isn't just a black-and-white
do this to that situation I also look at
these quarterbacks coming in now it
almost feels like the NFL is adopting
more of a college style that fits them
as they go in I know that some of the
Broncos one defensive back Chris Harris
I think said you know the Eagles are
running a college offense well so what
the NFL bought borrows more from college
than college borrows from the NFL and so
what if you're running a college style
offense that benefits Carson Wentz well
do me stop if you think it's a college
offense no it's that simple it's like
people get upset oh I can't stay in the
New England Patriots hey if you want to
be the best beat the best I think you
know sure it's it's a bit of a college
offense but you know Roger Staubach go
back 3035 years ran a shotgun offense
now everybody runs a shotgun so it's and
that's what they do in college the
difference is is we actually spend have
a chance at the professional level to
spend a lot more time in preparation
when it comes to being ready to play
football games at the college level I
think you get 20 hours a week to work
with the players four of which is now
the game so you get 16 hours a week to
put in some type of a simple offense or
some type of a simple defense at the
college level at our level you know
defensive coordinators I've known some
of its a hundred hours a week and you
know players aren't limited during the
season the amount of time they have to
spend to study and work so it resembles
a college offense but we don't get to
the line of scrimmage and look to the
sidelines which absolutely drives me
crazy they get ready to go and then
everybody everybody the offensive
lineman the wide everybody looks at the
sidelines if I was a defensive coach as
soon as you look to the sidelines I'd
change by defensive front
do you drive everybody nuts do you
consider Brady the best ever yes I do
and and you know Joe Montana I think
prior to Tom doing what he has done was
the greatest ever I mean certainly
Payton has accomplished awful lot but
when you and when you do what tom has
done with so many different people
around you
and you are the reason why the success
of the offense is what it is and I think
Bill Belichick's the greatest coach ever
also because you're always dealing with
moving parts it's not like you have the
same group of people around you I think
Joe for the four championships that he
won he had a pretty consistent group of
players around him offensive line wide
receivers running backs Tom it's been
like a turnstile you know it's like you
know I mean what 46 different receivers
30-some different running backs goodness
knows how many different combinations of
offensive lineman have played in that
offense he's been with Gronk without
rock with Julian without Julian I mean
but yet he continues to perform at an
extremely high level and so yeah I do I
think he's the greatest I've ever that's
ever played the game should we can
continue with Thursday Night Football no
I think Thursday Night Football has done
two things I think it's and I somewhat
agree with Michael Bennett although you
say Thanksgiving Day is a Thursday game
so it's a short week we've all we've all
prepared four short weeks so I don't
think that big a deal but I think
Thursday night has created a saturation
of professional football I think the
fans besides the things that have
happened with regard to kneeling and
outside the game I think the fans just
have seen so much of it that it's you
know what's so special about Thursday
night Monday night was always special
now truthfully Sunday Night Football is
replaced Monday Night Football as the
special night in my opinion when it
comes to viewing football and I just
think it's I think it's too much but the
economics are too big to walk away from
it dan but also you have these guys who
say hey we're exposing ourselves we're
risking injury and then you see what
happened with Russell Wilson he's trying
I don't know just be deceitful but he's
trying to avoid going into concussion
protocol so of course we can't you don't
want to do that I mean you don't want I
mean you know they asked him a bunch of
questions he passes he comes out I think
you know certainly the league wants to
do everything to protect the athlete and
Richard Sherman just as an example
whether Richard Sherman was going to get
hurt last night or whether it was going
to be next week
obviously he said that Achille been
achilles has been bothering him and
we've had interestingly enough if you
look at the last three or four years
there have been more and more Achilles
tendon problems than almost any injury
we've seen jr. galettes had to a lot of
different players have gone down with
with Achilles now what causes it I don't
know is it the way your body's made is
it the tendon in that area that gives
away you're not certain but you know
guys don't want to come off the field
yeah heck if we had with the rules that
we played under when I played if there
was concussion protocol you'd have
trouble putting an offense on the field
with quarterbacks or wide receivers or
running backs I mean the hits were
incredible but I'm all for safety and
I'm all for protecting the player I'm
all for that but you know sometimes just
looking at somebody you I don't know
what you can tell I'm not sure so you
know it's a system that has really just
come into place and I'm sure will be
more and more refined but both the
players and the owners want protection
for the athletes and I certainly
understand it
I had an eye-opening experience when I
was at the mothership and I was around
you guys on countdown when you were
working with those guys or we're at a
Super Bowl and the sense of humor that
former players have because you went
through one of the most grueling
injuries ever and I remember they would
have fun at your expense in front of you
and you somehow kept your composure with
these guys there at ESPN you remember
part of the game yeah absolutely we my
experience at ESPN was nothing but great
from from working with John wild hack
was my first producer and then Freddie
Goodell II was a second and then J
Rothman was the third when I worked
through three terrific producers of
football games and learned an awful lot
from them but you know it's part of the
game I mean we're gunfighters
competition junkie I love to compete but
you go out you go out there and you get
hurt it's part of the game I understand
that when I put the uniform on that
there's a possibility something that
happened certainly it did envision that
to be honest with you but you know
there's a possibility and you know I get
HEC when Robin Williams
who I think's more the funniest human
beings ever walked the face of the earth
he did Robin Williams at the Met he did
a skit on my Lake David Letterman David
took a pencil sharpener and did
something I mean I've had umpteen skits
done about my leg and you know I mean
people a lot of the world of seeing I
mean its head over what had a bet over a
10 or 12 million views on YouTube
and it's really funny because parents
will remember it the young generation
this generation doesn't but we just send
them to the internet so that they can
see exactly what happened yes the winds
of getting viewed a lot more it's always
great to catch up with you Joe thank you
we appreciate your time and good luck
this weekend thanks Dan preciate and
that's Joe Theismann joining us for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]